bang-bang what's up guys lunch money
time while she's trying to get rich the
rest of us just trying to get our lunch
money right I'm here with the beautiful
and intelligent Polina Mayer Nova she's
got a really soft shirt on today she
keeps trying to stop she keeps trying to
make me feel her shirt to know how soft
it is so for anyone watching at home
she's got a soft shirt on all right Jim
Cramer speaking though oh damn polina's
caught me again block by is the sponsor
get money get paid
don't forget black fights got three
products they allow you to buy and sell
cryptocurrency they allow you to deposit
crypto and to get a u.s. dollar loan and
also my favorite product as an investor
and a user is to deposit crypto and earn
up to eight point six percent APY for
those of you that don't know when you
deposit money in your bank account they
usually pay you like point zero five
percent black fight will pay you eight
point six percent there's risk do your
own research go check them out at block
by com
click the link in the description so we
get credit now let's get the Jim Cramer
we need we need a Jim Cramer but not no
we're good so you know how stocks have
been going up and everybody's like why
the hell are stocks going up when the
world is burning down well Jim Cramer
said the market has no conscience what
does that mean
well Jim Cramer is usually pretty
ridiculous I actually love him because I
think he's just funny he's a great
entertainer but I think he's right loud
yeah I think he's right
he's not sure called Mad Money on CNBC
that's pretty comical and entertaining
but I think he's definitely right the
stock market has no conscious meaning
that the stock market doesn't have
feelings it doesn't have emotions but I
thought investors are incredibly
emotional so how does that make sense
yes they are emotional in the sense of
when the prices are falling people will
sell when it's going up the FOMO in so
actually what's happening right now is
people are speculating on the economy is
reopening so here's the part that's
weird is everyone's looking at the
protest and saying oh my god there's
protests or social unrest there's all
these bad things you
but we had the economy it fell off a
cliff in terms of economic output
because we've sent everyone inside for
ten yeah now all of a sudden we're
starting to reopen the economy so yes
there are protests or all these things
but the bigger force is the fact that
now all these businesses are opening up
there's many more economic activity and
there should be a recovery in that day
so people are betting that there will be
a recovery so they're going to buy
stocks of course right so they're
speculating if there's gonna be future
recovery you see all the stocks rallying
then as the price rally it's like we've
seen everyone starts to FOMO in and buy
more and more more and it pushes the
prices up higher plus you layer in all
the Federal Reserve printing of money
they're literally propping up asset
prices and so like yes the riots are bad
that the protests are bad all of that is
kind of dominating the headlines right
now but if you look underneath of the
economic data basically that thing is is
getting better it's improving and that's
kind of the idea of the stock market not
having a conscience all right what's
going on with Dick's Sporting Goods
Dick's Sporting Goods I shop at Dick's
Sporting Goods why are you laughing
because I've bought so many things at
Dick's Sporting there's only two boxes
that show up at our apartment
Dixon Nike know and Amazon know not we
have so many boxes showing up at our
place it's like we're an Amazon
warehouse that's literally what I
thought he doesn't know that those are
from Dick's Sporting Goods okay somehow
I haven't me and my friend Kara have not
been enough to fuel the e-commerce a
part of Dick's so seems to Oh same store
sales that's why fall almost 30% during
coronavirus pandemic but ecommerce is
soaring thanks to me but they reported a
net loss of 143 million dollars for the
period ending May 2nd compared to at the
same time last year they made 57 million
so that's a literally a 200 million
dollar swing go from making 57 million
dollars in a quarter to now 147 million
dollar loss well maybe if they didn't
have 50% sales every day
well the 50% sales is just to keep the
revenue numbers up it's enticing you to
go buy things and if I make a little bit
of money on I have been
tyst but the problem is that they don't
have the in-store sales and so they're
getting just absolutely destroyed on
their other economics right I mean their
net sales fell about thirty-one percent
to 1.3 billion which is 600 million
lower than a year ago online sales were
up a hundred and ten percent for the
entire quarter so yeah but but you are
welcome well here's what's crazy is so
you see online sales go up over a
hundred percent and you still have total
sales down thirty percent so well
because the in-store sales were such a
higher percentage of sales right and so
even though that felt that fell so
drastically yes there's a hundred and
ten percent increase in online sales but
it didn't make up for it so it would
have needed to go up my guess is five
hundred percent and then they could have
made a profit don't worry I can still
saw some things to get alright what's
going on Bank of America
okay so wink of America is pledging 1
billion dollars to assist economic and
racial inequality intensified by the
pandemic so I I don't exactly understand
where it is putting the million dollars
it's just committing I don't know either
that look every single dollar helps and
it's great that Bank of America is
making this move there's no specific of
course and here's the the crazy part
right is the programs are gonna be
implemented they've got about 90 local
kind of like market presidents if you
will and those individual people are
going to implement these programs in
their local communities which is even
better right so it's not just going to
go to one organization and then kind of
get soaked up by salaries and stuff but
the the thing to me that I think is
interesting here is when Jeff Bezos or
some you know rich billionaire makes in
a donation like this everyone freaks out
like oh my god Jeff Bezos donating a
billion dollars is the equivalent of you
donating twenty dollars right why don't
they ever say that about the
corporations well correct me if I'm
wrong but I think people really like the
Bank of America CEO for some reason I've
seen him speak get interviewed he's very
kind of likable he's Irish
I don't know that has an enduring it
know America is just like the rest of
them
long Bitcoin short the bankers he's a
banker there are some details of where
the billion dollars will go it says it
will be appropriated for initiatives
including virus testing flu vaccine
clinics support for minority-owned small
businesses investments for affordable
housing and recruitment and retention of
staff from low to moderate-income
communities it's very interesting though
because like how do you fund programs oh
so I guess you fund the programs to
recruit people from look I appreciate as
long as well as there are many people
who appreciate this type of activity but
when you say that you are going to
recruit and retain staff from low to
moderate income communities and you make
this big announcement of a billion
dollars basically it's like that part of
the billion dollars are donating to
yourself right now I don't actually
think this is a donation what it sounds
like they're doing as we dig into the
details is they're setting it aside so
we're not giving it to other people
they're gonna use it internally but
they're gonna dedicate a billion dollars
of their balance sheet to go do this
it's a little bit different than a
charitable donation but still important
work right so I don't want to discount
the fact that they're actually putting a
billion dollars to work to do this type
of stuff but it's a little bit different
than just hey I'm donating two billion
dollars and so look hopefully it
actually out of just pure egotistical
competition other bank CEOs say hey we
should do that too and they start to say
well you did a billion I'll do one point
1 billion you did one point one I'll do
one point two right and we get more and
more money because there's a lot of
problems to solve speaking of problems
impossible burgers okay big problem have
you had one yeah did you like it it was
okay
really yeah did it taste like meat yeah
yeah jury's out a jury's out for me I
don't know so good finishers that no go
ahead finish it go ahead
no okay did you just they spell that
yeah is there like a ugh with an e
somewhere in the middle yeah all right
go ahead impossible burgers
[Music]
nestle well stop marketing its
plant-based burgers as incredible in
Europe after a Dutch Court found that
using the word infringes on an
impossible foods trademark I didn't know
that you could unfriend infringe on
someone's trademark even if it's not the
same word but only if it like it's ruled
to confuse customers because basically
nothing wanted to call it incredible
burgers but obviously impossible burgers
exist
I mean look pretty smart on Nestle
standpoint right put a big word a rat
with the letter I that is about the same
length across the front of it that you
know is fake meat yeah sure incredible
and possible it's all the same thing
right at least in the eyes of the
consumer but that's the Nestle no that's
what Nestle wants people to think right
as a guy impossible incredible whatever
but but obviously impossible burgers
doesn't want that okay so what if I
started a burger brand called ideal
burgers just because it starts with an
iron has an L does that mean they're
gonna sue me well it depends on if they
can prove that is it fake meat are you
marketing it the same like are you
trying to confuse the consumer now look
at the end of the day there's all kinds
of legal jockeying that goes on right
like oh you're infringing on this you're
infringing on that let me suit you the
here let me see you here you're talking
about these big multi-billion dollar
corporations who cares right well
impossible burgers obviously cares and
obviously joj cares and so does Nestle
because they're the ones who did it
right but like there's bigger things
going on in the world so I get they have
to protect their brand they have to
protect their business and I'm surprised
that this actually happened in a
European Court but I mean Nestle come on
yeah incredible burgers you like my new
lip gloss do you know where it's from
oh we know it's not a shoe I was gonna
say it's Kylie but it's not I just
realized sorry this is what I deal with
on a daily basis men just so you're
clear that was bait again I can complain
to the people all I want go ahead what's
up what's going on no I'm incredible I'm
incredible I'm not impossible I'm
incredible speaking of incredible what
about the incredible vacation
so tie hotels are offering luxury
quarantine packages is an alternative to
state-funded
isolation so it's so enjoy being
Thailand Thailand so it's allowing these
Bangkok hotels to offer luxury isolation
packages as an alternative to the
government-funded 14-day quarantine for
travelers so basically what happens
here's I believe the way that this works
is if you went on an international
flight that you previously were banned
from entering Thailand until the end of
June but the government has now allowed
people to come back to Thailand and
since you can't go home they're allowing
five specific hotels in Bangkok to offer
these like 14 day you know quarantine
package instead of containing at home or
wherever they want to put you for 14
days you can just go to the well in time
in Thailand you have to go to a state
designated quarantine utility yes so it
would be like the difference of like hey
you can go to this thing that used to be
in prison right or like you know hey
this holding cell like what where does
the state have quarantine
most of which are hotels I says I think
about them being pulled okay at this
fine state then there are hotels but my
point is that this state is telling you
where to go and now they're allowing you
to but you have to pay for the luxury
retreat I have no clue if we read the
internet I'm sure it'll tell us yes you
do it's $1,000 for a two-week stay
that's not bad if you live I mean if you
live in Thailand and you're like a
native Thai I think it's the correct
terminology I'm assuming that a thousand
island US dollars is a lot of money I
was gonna say I man's like notorious
would be one the cheapest places no well
I was gonna say if the state-funded
place is also a hotel like maybe it's
also nice I don't know if I'd pay a
thousand dollars just to be in the nice
one let's mine let's get to the meat we
got we got big news talk about
incredible and impossible guys you're
not gonna believe this it was Terrell
[ __ ]
Bastien go ahead tell him the news bang
bang we got Tiger king updates it's a
big day for Carroll Baskin why because
she there was a slaw suit and she was
awarded Joe it was Joe exotics Zoo Joe
exotic hannover Joe exotic had the zoo
in Oklahoma in the documentary Joe
exotic somehow had it transferred to
Geoff low who then everyone thought the
bad guy yeah hot nanny guy and everyone
thought that he was a bad guy cuz he
like stole it from Joe exotic well there
was a lawsuit and the judge has decided
that Geoff low and the animals they
gotta go
they gotta get out of the zoo and
Carroll [ __ ] bat she's taking over
gets the zoo now there's no animals in
the zoo but she gets the zoo this is the
ultimate pettiness this order gives
Baskin control of about 16 acres Wow
where the animals gonna go do we know
probably did the new zoo that Geoff Lowe
was already building he probably already
knew this yes yeah he probably knew this
was coming it in documented talk about
him well go ahead let me just tell you
if you know this like somebody who has a
birthday coming up cameo that that's
site all of the tiger king people are on
there so you can literally pay them to
tell him oh your birthday's coming up
news that's a good idea it's fake news
they're not they're not on there yes
they are
wait what do you mean I think there's
only there's only one or two of them on
there I okay well Jeff flow is
definitely on there okay but Joe exotic
is not well he's in prison yeah but
that's the one when I would want to say
happy birthday to me he's Jones I would
be sad you would be Anthony Anthony
it was Carolyn Bastion but how happy
would you be if I if I got you a
birthday video with Carol asking wishing
you a hey you call cat and kitten no why
no that's dumb why Joe exotic or I'm I
don't care yes guys by the way what do
you think his reaction was in prison
when he heard that Carol [ __ ]
askin is getting his zoo he's not happy
he's salty I bet can you imagine him
running around that prison freaking out
I just cannot picture Joe exotic in
prison like having friends oh they
probably all want to beat the hell out
of him
yeah but knowing as voice walking around
thinking he's cool no I do look at your
haircut come on wait can he he hasn't
seen the documentary in prison right I'm
sure somebody somehow has gotten him
access to watching it at this point
whether they mail them a DVD but it also
depends like can he have any sort of
electronics I have no clue but
somebody's seen it and told them about
it for sure right through phone calls
and stuff like that there is no comment
by Baskin yeah look the by the way this
is what ends up happening in a society
where okay you're right all of Jeff's
focus is on opening the new Tiger king
Park and Thacker Ville Oklahoma which
should be opening in the next 120 days
Wow Wow you do redo you guys you see
that that's called I do though my
homework I do what's necessary to for
the people he's that kid so in high
school I was the kid that was like if
the teacher forgot you know to collect
the homework I Vic
excuse me like did you did you forget
because I did it like do you want it Oh
kidding okay you're not kidding about
the homework no I would I would private
work what am I supposed to do okay well
you are the kid we're gonna wear it I
need to reassess some things here you're
the kid they're like what did you go
homework and then you would randomly get
called on and you'd somehow have the
answer I never be like oh oh I would be
intelligent shocking no yeah listen
because if you understand how school
works you realize you don't need to do
the work and you don't actually need to
pay attention to 99% of the things you
just got to know though like ten things
that the teacher cares about and once
you can identify those okay like for the
tiger team they'd be like oh what's JLo
gonna do like have a new Park and they'd
like damn didn't get them that time and
then they're like how did you know that
you're like well what else would you ask
him but it's like five things you could
ask me about that
obvious next step easy
I read the Internet I memorized things
and then when people would ask me
questions I realized that in school all
you had to do is regurgitate what the
teacher already said like schools dumb
because all they do is they sit there in
front of the class no this is I had to
synthesize I had to write essays this is
all they did in school they said okay
we're going to teach you today about
English literature and they would sit up
there and they would literally hand you
a syllabus they then would sit and talk
all class they would write things on the
board and then they would give you a
book and tell you to read it and once
they did those three things then they'd
say okay here's a test and all they're
doing is they're testing what they
already told you it's stupid so as a kid
all you had to realize was okay what are
the five major things that they're gonna
ask me on this test if I get four of the
five I'm likely to get an 80 and if I
get an 80 it's a beer or a see what
depending on what school you went to and
C's get degrees so like I'll see y'all
later
go ahead nerds go do all of your stay up
till two o'clock in the morning doing
school I'm talking to girls I'm trying
to make money I got important things to
do play video games work out you know
watch movies read the internet I was
compounding my knowledge that's what I
was doing he was he was doing worksheets
and homework
I don't even how to spell homework but
look at me you ended up here and so did
I so who spent their time better alright
anything else with the people it's not
from dicks where is it from
I'll think about it I mean I just gotta
say it like who thought the name the
place dicks just saying alright guys
that's it for lunch money well Wall
Street's trying to get rich the rest of
us just trying to get our lunch money
right we will see you tomorrow who's
name is Richard it was Darryl [ __ ]
Baskin bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block 5 so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on I'm an investor
user and a huge fan what you're a bigger
fan of block fire than you are of me
block wise my second favorite thing in
the world behind Polina
they've got three products they can give
you a US dollar loan you can earn up to
eight point six percent interest on an
interest-bearing account or you can buy
and sell crypto currencies on their
crypto exchange I personally use the
interest-bearing account there's not
very many places where you'll find up to
eight point six percent interest on a
deposit in an interest-bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but eight point six percent
it's pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks that block by subscribe to our
channel like the video annoy playing in
the comment and we'll see you guys
tomorrow
and be kind to your friends